hey 42 here imagine you're the captain
of a large cruise ship steaming across
the North Atlantic Ocean it's a cold
night and you can see nothing but stars
and endless Blackness your mustache is
twitching a sure sign you're feeling
uneasy and not just because you had a
bit too much Chevy with dinner
out here in the freezing open ocean you
know there's one risk to your ship
greater than any other and that risk is
flooding
yes unsurprisingly the most common
reason ships sink is because they fill
with water but if you fell for my
careful priming the first thing that
popped into your head was probably
icebergs
of course that would have been wrong
because there probably aren't many
icebergs around these days
but inappropriate climate change jokes
and my subtle nudging aside there's
another obvious reason an iceberg may
have bobbed into view in your mind's eye
just now
because of the sinking of the Titanic by
far the most famous Maritime disaster of
all time
it's a tragic story and not just because
scientists have recently proven
something we've all suspected for a long
time that Jack actually could have
survived if he just climbed on that damn
door next to Rose but a staggering 1 500
Souls perished at night when the
unsinkable ship did the unthinkable and
sank
but that doesn't even come close to
topping the list of the deadliest
Maritime disasters in history because
there's something far scarier than giant
ice cubes lurking out there in the ocean
us
what really causes large-scale loss of
human life at Sea are not icebergs but
Torpedoes shelling mines depth charges
and when all else fails Kamikaze
Fighters
according to one prominent inshorah in
2020 a total of 48 ships were lost
worldwide
by comparison between 1939 and 1945 14
341 ships were sunk
that's more than 2 000 ships per year
yet even in the company of such morbid
statistics the sinking of one ship in
particular stands out for the almost
unimaginable scale of its tragedy and
strangely enough you've probably never
even heard of it
because for reasons which will soon
become clear the story of The Wilhelm
Gustav has largely been forgotten by
history and to resurrect it we're going
to have to go back in time to January
1945.
foreign
now I'd like to take a moment to talk
about hair loss because I've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s and it's always been
an upsetting experience if you're in the
same boat then you're not alone did you
know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35.
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left I really like keeps
because it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in Pharmacy checkout lines
there's a good reason that keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trust them for their hair loss
prevention medication
so if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it for a limited time go to
keeps.com
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50 off your first order
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this
video
the second world war is nearing its end
and the Russian army was advancing on
Europe from the East intent on putting
an end to Nazi Germany's hopes of
establishing the third right the Russian
army wasn't exactly known for its kind
and merciful treatment of Germans
military personnel or otherwise and so
quite possibly the largest mass
evacuation in history began on the
Eastern front under the name of
operation Hannibal although a large
number of civilians were taken back to
Germany the number one aim of operation
Hannibal was to bring a large chunk of
the remaining German Army back to the
Fatherland to continue the fight at home
habble lasted for 115 days in the spring
of 1945.
during which time as many as 2 million
people were evacuated
by contrast the famous operation Dynamo
that saw the rescue of 338 000 Allied
troops from the beaches of Dunkirk had
taken just nine days in May and June of
1940. during the evacuation of Dunkirk
every available ship or boat was drafted
in for the rescue of the troops and the
same was true of operation Hannibal
but there was certainly a discrepancy in
scale dunkirk's of about 235 boats sunk
and an estimated 5 000 soldiers lost
during the evacuation
during operation Hannibal only 10 more
ships a total of 245 were lost
but there were more than 33
000 fatalities
and almost a third of them belonged to
just one ship The Wilhelm Gustav a huge
vessel that had originally been
commissioned by the Nazi party as a
cruise liner on the 30th of January 1945
The Wilhelm Gustav was sunk in the
Baltic Sea by a Soviet torpedo
the gold stuff was carrying Germans from
occupied countries like Lithuania
Estonia Latvia and East Prussia
though there were also military
personnel aboard the passengers were
mainly civilians
by most standards these were innocent
people but this was the tail end of the
biggest war in history and the innocence
of German civilians wasn't quite so
straightforward in the eyes of many as
it might have been otherwise
fair or not that judgment made sure the
incredible tragedy of the sinking of the
Wilhelm gulstov very probably the
greatest Maritime disaster ever never
made it into the history books
at over 200 meters long and weighing
more than 25
000 tons the gulstov was launched on the
5th of May 1937 to Great fanfare being
the centerpiece of the kdf fleet it was
originally going to be called the Adolf
Hitler
the kdf which stood for craft dirt
freuder or strem through Joy was a
state-run Leisure organization set up in
1933 to reward the German people for
good behavior by giving them access to
fun activities
you could say that kdf put the party
into Nazi party
in the end Wilhelm Gustav's name was
chosen for the ship he'd been the leader
of the Nazi party in Switzerland before
being assassinated by a Jewish medical
student in 1936.
after sitting next to golstop's Widow at
the memorial service Hitler decided on
the name change in wilhelm's honor Frau
gulstaff was even invited to officially
launch the ship before and during the
war devoted workers and Nazi officials
were rewarded with cruises and concerts
aboard the goldstev on its unofficial
maiden voyage in 1938 the ship took
austrians on a four-day Cruise in a not
so subtle attempt to get them to vote
for the annexation of Austria by Germany
a neat little maneuver known today as
the Angelus in reality the Austrian
populace were being threatened with a
swift death for voting against
annexation so being bribed with
champagne and seasickness probably
wasn't necessary
the cool stuff took over 80 000
passengers on Pleasure cruises between
March 1938 and the outbreak of war in
September 1939. at which time it was
recommissioned for use as a hospital
ship for the first year of the war
towards the end of 1940 things changed
again and all the medical equipment was
removed and the gold stuff became a
Barrack ship for Submariner trainees in
Poland then not much happened for the
ship and its crew for the next four
years
but in 1945 it was perfectly placed to
help in the evacuation efforts of
operation Hannibal and it was converted
again this time into an escape boat
by the time the operation began most of
the available ships were in Fairly poor
condition and the Allied Forces had firm
grip on the skies whilst the Baltic Sea
was heavily mined and teeming with
Russian submarines oh and despite what I
said earlier it was a brutally cold
winter so yeah icebergs were actually a
genuine danger too
all in all the deck was heavily stacked
against the fleeing Germans
and it was to passengers of The Wilhelm
gulshtof that paid the maximum price on
the 30th of January 1945 the port of
gadinia was full of thousands of
refugees including women and children
soldiers Nazi officials and U-Boat
trainees all desperate to get away the
Goldstock was the largest ship available
but it had only been designed to carry
1900 people including its crew
by the time it set sail there were more
than five times that number on board
some people had tickets but most simply
forced their way onto the ship and who
could blame them
when the options are Escape or death
you're going to give escape a go no
matter how dangerous it might seem
according to records there were 6 000
passengers and crew aboard the ship but
the real number is thought to be upwards
of ten thousand ninety percent of whom
were civilians when the ship left Port
just after midday it was hugely
overcrowded with people occupying every
space they could find including the long
empty swimming pool but nobody was
working on their tan records say it was
snowing that day and the Mercury was at
10 degrees below freezing inside the
ship however the sheer number of people
ensured the atmosphere was hot and humid
and many resorted to removing their life
jackets in an attempt to cool down
yeah in hindsight that wasn't ideal but
then again a bit of extra buoyancy
wouldn't have made all that much
difference in the freezing Waters of the
Baltic Sea in what sounds like the start
of a bad joke there were four captains
aboard the ship and they couldn't agree
on the safest route to take
some wanted to stick to the shallower
waters along the coastline to minimize
the chances of encountering submarines
whilst others fought the deeper
mind-swept waters further out to sea
were their best bet
in the end they opted for the latter
at around 6 PM a German mine sweeping
Convoy was spotted in the area and to
avoid any sort of collision one of the
captains ordered at the goldstev's red
and green navigation lights be turned on
lighting the ship up like a floating
Christmas Tree by 7 PM the gold stuff
was being tailed by a Soviet submarine
called s13
even though a torpedo boat was
accompanying the Gustav to protect her
against Subs its submarine detector and
anti-aircraft guns had been frozen
leaving the vessel totally unprotected
s13 reeled in the gulstuff during a
two-hour Chase before firing four
Torpedoes there are rumors that each of
the Torpedoes had been adorned with a
hand-painted message and even though the
fourth missile got wedged in the
submarine's torpedo tube the other three
successfully delivered their mail
within an hour the goldstuff had sunk
dozens of people were killed instantly
by the blasts and thousands more were
drowned trapped below the decks those
who made for the lifeboats had to
navigate a Stampede in which panicked
passengers were crushed to death
all but nine of the lifeboats were
frozen in place and even those that were
broken free were difficult to release
because one of the Torpedoes had hit the
cruise quarters killing the only people
who knew how to operate them
still several lifeboats did start
getting lower towards the sea but about
20 minutes after the first torpedo found
its Mark the ship suddenly listed
violently to Port
the lifeboats that were being glued on
the opposite side of the ship were
smashed into the Gustav's Hull
destroying them and casting their
occupants into the freezing Waters below
the few lifeboats that did make it down
safely were soon faced with a new threat
boarding from the hundreds of swimmers
already in the water
eyewitness accounts speak of desperate
men and women trying to haul themselves
aboard the lifeboats whilst the current
occupants beat them back with fists ores
and some Choice German swear words
support boats did eventually arrive and
between them they were able to rescue
about 1 250 people through the night
they were very very lucky ones
nobody knows exactly how many people
died that night but most estimates put
the figure at around 9 400 poor souls
that's more than six Titanics or three
September 11th
the last survivor was found at dawn when
a German naval officer climbed into a
drifting Lifeboat to check for signs of
Life at first he found none but amongst
the bodies was a baby that had been
tightly wrapped in blankets
it was still alive
the same officer will go on to adopt and
raise the child as his very own in what
was one of the few tiny bright points on
one of the blackest nights in Maritime
history
[Music]
thanks for watching